I'm Rick Prum it's a pleasure
this lecture sponsored by the Frankie
program in science and humanities
great ee b turnout so so who for most of
you this this introduction will will be
unnecessary however this is my first
opportunity ever to introduce gunther
and so i'm gonna take full advantage of
that of that now so first I'd like to
thank the Franky's rich and Barbara
Franken for their ongoing support for
the Frankie program they have so many
rich and important connections to Yale
today they're actually hosting the
Frankie graduate fellow shindig which is
right now over in the Graduate School
they are responsible for supporting some
twenty or thirty graduate students right
now across the university so so they
cannot be here today's lecture is in his
next in a series inspired by a
collaboration with Bob Schulman over the
summer last year I said to Bob hey we
really ought to cook up something
related to your new book and over a
series of lunches we identified the
basically a theme in in in the area of
philosophy individuality and the
humanities so various areas in which
philosophy and active engagement
philosophy is important to to to the
quality of science and Gunter's talks
today or because in this regard Gunter
is a great example in-house talent as
somebody who's been engaging with
philosophy in their work for their whole
career so Gunter is the Allyson Richard
professor of the ecology and
evolutionary biology and a professor in
systems biology Institute on Yale's West
Campus he received a BS in chemistry at
the college for chemical engineering in
Vienna and a PhD in biology from the
University of Vienna I think that was
the first sign that he was exiting the
comfortable world of the law like in
favor of the more interesting and rich
opportunities to study evolutionary
biology he taught for some years at
University of Vienna and then has been
here at Yale since in 1991 he's been
active in the creation of the ebee
Department in the late 90s has served
multiple times as a chair he's also
served as director of the Yale systems
biology Institute and he is the editor
of two companion journals the Journal of
experimental swallow G and a special
edition of that the molecular and
developmental evolution Gunther is the
recipient of the MacArthur Fellowship
and has an amazingly diverse research
program on the side of theory he's been
working for many years on theoretical
population genetics a homology and
character identity modularity evolute
evolvability innovation and novelty and
gene regulatory networks so these are
all fields in which if you go into the
late 20th century work and try to dig
down and find out what's there you find
a good ters name throughout the
essentially the foundations of what are
now whole old disciplines on the
empirical side a good has been very
interested in digit identity and the
evolution of the vertebrate hand
more recently the evolution of the
uterus plantation and the origin of
mammalian pregnancy cell type evolution
and the role of transpose vilela meant
sin the origin of novelty now I first
met Gunther back in 2001 at a meeting in
Beijing on dinosaur and bird origins it
was an exciting time for me I was trying
to advertise and get out these crackpot
ideas on the origin of feathers and and
Gupta was a very sympathetic and
interested voice in those early years
it's been a great pleasure to be a
colleague of of Gunter's here at Yale
and he's been really been an inspiration
one of the remarkable things about
gunther and i is that we are
intellectual poles polar opposites I'm
basically a bird watcher and he's
basically a mathematician by which I
mean if you anesthetize us and then and
then brought us back and find out which
of our intellectual faculties came
through first for me it would be this
natural history organ of the brain and
for him it would be mathematical
analysis yet despite the fact that we
have this utter difference in our sort
of intellectual foundations for some
reason over the years we have converged
on on a major agreement on almost every
suspect of evolutionary biology and and
and I'm still working on species
concepts I think I can get him to move
closer to me and that one but it besides
that we're really really really close
and and this has been really fortunate
so we've taught several times in the
recent past together and the experience
is the combination of finishing each
other's sentences and then he'll say
something that just completely blows my
mind in an unexpected way and so that
makes it a fantastic colleague so today
is also an interesting opportunity
because we are expanding the usual
reception into a book party because now
available are available in 13 days from
amazon.com is Gunter's new book homology
genes and evolutionary innovation
published by Princeton University Press
so please join us afterwards for an
extra-special reception celebrating
Gunther and the release of his book so
it's a great pleasure to introduce
Gunther today who's be speaking on the
metaphysics of homology and the
molecular basis of character identity
thank you
this slide I know okay Rick thank you
very much for this kind introduction
thank you all of to you for coming today
and giving some of your time to hear a
talk about homology it's really amazing
I'm honored that you all are here thank
you very much it's great and as as Rick
has already alluded to at the talk today
that we agreed upon to Velichko
coincides with the publication of my new
book homology genes and evolutionary
innovations and I hope you always stay
and and and and join us at the party now
when I started working on this project
here to write the book and actually
before that even trying to understand
the problem of homology I quickly
realized that I had actually two types
of problems at my hand it's not only a
scientific problem trying to understand
the particular pattern of evolutionary
diversity and try to tie it to the
genetic mechanisms to developmental
mechanisms and evolutionary mechanisms
but at the same time it turned out to be
also a problem that is deeply rooted in
metaphysical assumptions that various
research programs have so it turns out
that I've realized that the two aims
here in the title that this strange
juxtaposition in a scientific talk name
a metaphysics and molecular mechanisms
actually have to go hand-in-hand we
cannot address the one without the other
because you know they are just
interdependent of each other and that's
the reason why I am happy to have the
opportunity here to talk in in the
Whitney amenities Center and the Frankie
program too about this particular topic
because it really spans both
mechanistically aspects as well as
conceptual and and and ontological
aspects of of metaphysics but let me
first start a little bit explaining what
homology is about the
even though there is a large contingent
of EB students and faculty here there
are also members of other disciplines
here it's a very base of everything to
FS point or anything like that laser
pointer anyways there used to be one
that one doesn't seem to have an exit
anyway might not be necessary that much
so at the very base of it homology
concept is a way to think about basic
observation does it that even if you
compare relatively distantly related
organisms very often you find body parts
that you cannot escape noticing that
they are in some way are the same thing
like tetrapod limbs forgive me that i
was mixing up for alley behind limbs
here but this is besides the point you
know in frogs and birds and cats Salem
and doesn't even in you know in fossil
fishes we find appendages to the body
that in spite of all the dissimilarities
all the differences in size and number
of elements and proportions you know if
I want the feeling that one is still
dealing with the same thing in in a
certain sense of course now it is thank
you and how does it work out this week
okay in a certain sense we explain the
presence of corresponding body parts as
being due to the inheritance of the same
thing in a common interest and I chose
here three examples of a fossil form and
two recent forms to emphasize that
homology is not about similarity
actually you know the hand of a human
and the hand of a period or the wing of
a period are quite dissimilar in
superficially spoken the number of
elements and how they are fused and so
on and actually the ancestral form not
only had five digits but actually up to
eight so so we talked about the wing and
the hand as being the same
thing because it's derived from a
corresponding part in a in the common
ancestor
now homology is one of these concepts
that biologists cannot live with it and
cannot live without it at the same time
and so you get quotes from the same
author actually that the one hand
asserts that homology is fundamental for
much of comparative biology in biology
in general but on the other hand a few
years later David vague asserts that
there's no reason to seek a naturalistic
explanation for instances of homology
biologists should instead 20 attention
to questions that can be resolved so
it's a quite pessimistic but quite
reasonable assessment because you know
it is discordance about these topics for
about 150 years since this concept was
actually defined in the in pre
evolutionary times so let me just
quickly say why I think homology is so
hard in particular homology of
characters is so hard to nail down the
one hand body parts you know like hands
and eyes and so on are not directly
inherited they are not inherited like
DNA they are not copied directly but
they have to develop in each generation
and use it is the way how the things are
transmitted is quite indirect compared
to DNA for instance and in starting in
the 20th century early in the 20th
century and became absolutely clear with
molecular developmental biology this
also became clear that the same body
part can actually be dependent on
different sets of genes in different
species so the mechanistic underpinnings
at least some of the pay mechanistic
underpinning of the same thing can
actually be different so we cannot just
say well that the the homo log like the
limp is just an epiphenomenon of the
continuity of the genes because the
continuity of the genes is also not
happening right at least not in a direct
way and then there are also conceptual
hurdles that need to be overcome in
order to you know be meaningfully talk
about these issues so what do I mean by
direct and indirect inheritance as I
said in the case of homologous genes in
different species it's relatively
straightforward to understand what's
meant by that because genes are produced
by a direct copying process and actually
the two copies of a of an ancestral gene
are also the material overlap because
half of the molecule actually comes from
the parental DNA so that's is relatively
clear how inheritance and continuity of
information is possible at the level of
the DNA sequences on the other hand as I
mentioned in in anything that is
phenotypic more on the organismal level
everything comes from a single cell
model or you know other forms of rare
forms of asexual reproduction but let's
say in vertebrates it all becomes from a
single cell that intent develops and
there is no direct coupling copying of
the multicellular body parts they all
have to go through a single cells as the
stage and therefore the mode of
inheritance is much more indirect and in
the case of them just a one example of
many many that exist in the literature
about the same organ having different
developmental mechanisms underneath it
is the bulb of the of senioritis and
nematodes you know all of them have the
same Wolvie
they are clearly homologous there's
continuity of this form but inductive
signals that are producing the vulva
cells in scenery up titers in place
cause because are quite different and
you know you can can make the argument
that at least part of the developmental
program has actually changed since the
most recent common ancestor of these two
species so just to make that and that is
not a really new discovery it was
already realized by hunter Feynman and
he'll then mangle so Feynman was the
researcher who discovered in embryonic
induction meaning the fact that some
cells tell their neighboring cells what
to do by some kind of
signal wonder of the famous examples was
the development of the lens in the in
the eye which seems to depend on a
signal from the eye cup during
embryogenesis that if you take away the
eye cup the lens doesn't develop but it
turns out when they stayed the same
experimented some other species of frogs
they could take out the eye cup and
still the lens would develop which means
there's also an alternative ways of
inducing the development of the same
structure and different species even
within the same sort of larger group of
of toads and and frogs so so that was
actually Feynman was originally trained
as a comparative anatomist and it was
very much of the air of the importance
and the difficulty of the problem of
homology and in 1915 he published a
paper on the history and the critique of
the concept of homology in which his
conclusion was there is no relationship
between any mechanistic understanding of
development and the notion of homology
in the terms of continuity of the same
thing through time so the question is of
course very briefly why's homology as a
topic as a concept still important I
think there are two main reasons the one
is that homology reflects one of the
major patterns of biological diversity
simply the fact that body planes tends
to be tend to be conserved and you find
again and again the same building blocks
in in quite if distantly related
organisms so in that way we cannot just
ignore it but may be even more important
for the development of our own science
is that I think understanding homology
is fundamental for our understanding of
evolutionary innovation I think one of
the big or open questions in
evolutionary biology is to understand
how complex organisms arise and I think
we can not understand how novelty arises
if you don't understand what sameness
means right so homology is about the
identity of body parts and innovation is
of how about the origin of such body
parts it is similar to the problem of
species origins only after biologists
have understood what species are about
about in sexually reproducing species
the separation of gene pools and so on
was it possible to develop a meaningful
and productive research program into the
Origin of Species right if you don't
know about the species it's hard to find
out how they originated and a lot of the
research prior to this phase in
evolution of biology this research was
about how to change an organism but it
wasn't about how and you species arises
so that was I think in the same sense we
need to have a some level of
understanding what homologies what
character the entities in order to
understand how new character identities
originate what we need to know in order
to understand the origin of a new body
part ok and if someone is tempted to
argue that nothing is new in evolution
it's actually some people are honestly
are doing I challenge him or her to tell
me what corresponds let's say to the
task of a elephant in the trachea plucks
our species right so at some points
these parts that are individualized in
vertebrates have to originate and they
were not there before . there is just no
way around it right so origin novelty is
a real problem that we need to
understand ok that was the introduction
I want to divide the rest of the talk
into two parts the one is talked about a
little bit about the anatomy of the
homology concept how it changed over
there over there over the centuries and
and then make a proposal that links
homology concept with a mechanistic
understanding of development and then
the second part I'm asking the where is
the metaphysics coming in why is it
necessary to address also in
philosophical issues in particular
questions of what's real and what's not
real
namely the ontology so let's start with
the anatomy of the homology concept and
order for make the communication more
efficient I will first list the main
points that I want to make and
go through them one by one and explained
and a little bit more so one point is
one has to realize that homology as it
was originally defined by Owen in the
mid nineteenth century was about
corresponding body parts it was not
about similarities or shapes or whatever
it was about corresponding body parts
now it is and after Darwin we explain
homology or character identity as in
historical continuity of descent that is
credited to Lancaster although it's
implicit in in Darwin and then my point
is that character taint is only
meaningful if we talk about
individualized body parts it's not just
anything that we can describe separate
out out of the body that it's meaningful
to talk about character identity it has
to be developmentally individualized
from the rest of the body and and
character identity and character States
different ways how they can be formed
actually I hypothesized and will give
you some evidence for that are based on
different genetic substrates that a
certain genes whose job it is to
determine character identity and other
genes that determine character States
the way it is shaped in a particular
species in particular time so the
classical definition of homology going
back to owen 1843 simply says homologue
is the same organ in different animals
under any variety variety of form and
functions that is still a pre
evolutionary definition of homology but
has important elements that we shouldn't
forget the first of all I already
mentioned Owen speaks about the same
organ clearly a body part not some you
know some some attribute to the of an
animal it's also clearly speaking of
sameness in under every variety of form
and function and that to me means that
he clearly abstracts work work an
identity were body part at the end
from the particular character state the
form and function that it takes in a
particular form in a particular species
of course the main unsolved conceptual
and also mechanistic problem is what we
really mean by the same if it can be of
any shape and function right so what is
then the basis of our calling something
the same thing even though it's not even
the same thing right then comes ray
Lancaster who is credited with sort of
the first one explicitly linking
character at the entity or homology to
descent from a common ancestor but what
I want to point out is that in his
definition he still clearly talks about
organs corresponding ordering organs and
body parts you know that working in an
animal Alfa and organ P in the animal P
and so on as this being derived from the
same organ in the common ancestor and so
on right so that's the sort of the
textbook definition that we are using
nowadays if we talk about teach homology
in in courses but still this unresolved
problem is here because we still use the
term the same character in an undefined
way only that we say it's the same
character in a common ancestor but don't
actually say what sameness means here
now then something bad happened as usual
in the 20th century then there was a
loss of specificity in the talk about
homology and it's you can trace this
back to influential definitions by the
most influential proponents of the new
synthesis Simpson and Ernst Maya where
Simpson for instance talks about
homologies resemblance whatever you know
and any level due to inheritance or
common ancestry or Maya talks about
attributes of two organisms are
homologous blah blah blah right and I
think this lack of precision leads to a
major source of confusion because in
that sense you can use homology for two
different kinds of things you can
characterize say well two character
states are homologous they are come from
the common ancestor let's say a
particular nucleotide in particular
position in that in a DNA sequence as
well as you can use it for character
identities the presence or absence of a
body part or the presence or absence of
an amino acid in a sequence or a
nucleotide but those are actually two
quite different biological realities
that we are talking about here and it's
important to realize that confusing
using the same term for both notions
it's actually leading to confusion now I
have already used the distinction
between character States and character
identities extensively so I probably owe
you a little bit more explanation of
what I mean by that the easiest example
that I find is if you look at insect
wings most clerical insects have two
pairs of things four wings and hind
wings in most of the species it's a wing
plate that is good for producing lift
but it's some lineages there is only one
leaf producing pair of panda cheese like
in the tip tara in the Flies and mulatos
snarking and english whatever yeah yeah
whatever
you have one pair the second pair you
have a second pair of appendages but
they are not wings in the in the in the
everyday language but they are whole
tear sort of sensory organs and in the
case of beetles you have also one pair
of wings that are actually used for
flying and another pair the four wings
in that case is transformed into an
illiterate which is a protective cover
over the back of the of the animal so
the the point here is that we have
actually two character identities for
being identity hind wing identity which
in butterflies can be being played in
untipped or the following can be a wing
plate and the hind being is a deer or in
the
in the in the beetle stuff for being as
an illiterate and the wing blade is it's
at the hind wing is a wing plate so the
character identities are forming and
hind wing and wing plate or healthy are
literal character states of either for
being a hind wing right so that's that's
the distinction as well as I just said I
think that this distinction between
character identities and character
States the various realizations of an
individualist body part is important
because it's also as consequences for
for the mechanistic understanding named
it the idea is that developmentally
developmental or individualization which
is this is losing its power if someone
else has another laser pointer that the
developmental individuality that's
necessary for character identity is
actually caused by gene specific gene
regulatory networks that enable the
expression of differential sets of
effector genes and I want to justify
this conclusion by using actually quite
this example of forming and hiding
identity because you know fly
development is something that was
investigated quite extensively now it
turns out that for a fly to have a
healthier have this little Club like
appendages in the on the on the back of
their thorax requires that the
expression of a particular gene called
upx ultrabithorax the function of upx
interest off eliza
is to suppress a number of genes that
are known to be necessary to make a wing
plate to something you spread out and be
flattened and reach it you know solve
being as AC and so on all of them they
are inhibited by ubxou' could be excused
to think of that a Drosophila upx gene
is a gene that inhibits genes necessary
for making a wing plate so you could
think upx is an
wing blade gene so it prevents the
formation of a wing plate right
essentially right but if that would be
the case then you would expect that the
four winged species doesn't express ubx
in the hind wing right but that's
exactly what's happening so here you
have a Drosophila mr. mr. mr. Hult here
this is the embryonic structure that
from which to LTS forming and the green
fluorescence here shows the expression
of ubx in the in a butterfly the hind
wing also expresses ubx so it upx is not
always suppressing in all species
suppressing the formation of a wing
plate right so what is it then doing
it's even present in primarily wingless
species in the third segment of the
thorax and that's actually also the case
in in in Tripoli in you know near which
is a butterfly and so on but the
critical experiment a really a striking
one is a knockdown of upx function in
tribolium okay so so these are this is
the effect of losing ubx activity in the
hind wing and interest offered and a few
other genetic factors and you get two
wings you could say well you know you're
just get you know you get the full beam
phenotype back but the same explanation
is not possible if you look at the
outcome of a knockdown of the upx gene
in tribolium you get also four
appendages but there are two pairs of a
litora okay so what that clearly shows
what the role of ubx is is not to
determine the shape of the after out of
the second appendage but actually to
determine hind wing identity and when
you take away ub eggs you are left with
two identical appendages that are both
of for being identity okay so ubx is not
determining the shape of the appendage
or the phenotype per se but it is one
that determines that the second pair
of appendages is a hind being identity
rather than for being and if you take it
away you get for being identity as a
default state okay
so that already shows that UVA exists as
a the character at the entity gene not a
gene that determines a particular
phenotype so it's a character identity
and character state a two aspect of body
organization that are the result of
manifestations of different
developmental mechanisms the problem
though is that if you manipulate a gene
that affects Caragh identity you also
get a different phenotype right but you
can in principle and in evolutions
happens have different character states
with the same character identity with
the same character identity genes being
active but that led me to this cartoon
model that sort of summarizes how
character identity and character
development of body part and even cell
type identities is working and I posited
a sort of three three levels to be
distinguished the one is positional
information signals the inductive
signals the one cell tells the other
cell what to do and where it is and what
time it is and and that interesting
thing so these are the things that we
have seen in in nematode development
that are quite variable that is the
examples of inductive differences in the
in eye development at feynman and
mangled have discovered so positional
information even though absolutely
necessary in the end in the development
of a particular species can be variable
between between species okay that is all
the examples where developmental
mechanisms seem to be different for
homologous genes that I know of can be
interpreted as difference in positional
information signaling the positional
information signals then activate what I
call a character identity nectar or gene
that also can be called coup regulatory
network in the cell
Piper the entity and this level of
regulation is actually quite conserved
we'll give you some examples later and
this this network mostly consists of
transcription factors and consider
transcriptional regulators as well as
probably also long non-coding RNAs and
are quite conserved and quite rigidly
associated with character identity and
date and regulate what we could realize
our genes the genes that have gene
products that actually do physiological
work like enzymes contractile
cytoskeletal proteins XSL other proteins
and oh and all of that right now the
important point here is if character
identity is actually associated with
character identity networks it's quite
obvious that's the same character that
entity network can regulate different
sets of realized genes because it only
depends on the presence of absence of
particular sister egg you Latorre
elements in there realize a gene whether
they are either suppress to activate it
by it now that explains how the
mechanistically character states the
phenotype can be dissociated from
character identity because the same
character identity that allows
differential regulation can actually
differentially regulate different sets
of target genes right so that's so my
answer to what can what does it mean to
be the same thing and every variety of
form and function become form and
function depends on the realized change
that you're expressing while character
identity fundamentally is the ability to
be different how different were in what
way different is open right so that's
what I'm saying here XI character
tainted in networks enables the
expression of different realized genes
but do not rigidly determine which
realized genes are expressed that can
change in evolution so different sets of
realized genes can be controlled by the
same gene in different species
that sort of allows for this strange
conceptual disassociation between being
the same thing under every variety of
form and function so so so what the chin
thereby the carrick identity network
actually does is enables the expression
of different realizes genes but in a way
for our philosophically trained
colleagues here one could say character
identity is the condition for the
possibility of being different so it's
the bidding on the team for the mudra
card form a transcendental a figure of
thinking like in can't it is not a
particular outcome it it's the
possibility for particular outcomes
right just so that I assert that you
know core regulatory networks is not
just something that I made up on the
weekends there is actually quite a
number of cell type identity networks we
worked out here is one example for liver
cells and all of these these character
identity matrix always have the
character of actually a positively
regulating each other so they are all
necessary for each other and stabilize
their expression relative to each other
another example is the core regulatory
network for embryonic stem cells with
three members and in this context I also
want to point out that another
characteristic that is in particular
important for the lab and the work in my
lab is that the that the transcription
factors that are coded for by the chains
in the in the core regulatory networks
are actually obligatory interacting on
Co cooperative to affect the expression
of any target gene so they are not just
a combination of independent or
scripture factors but they actually have
to cooperate and I think that's also the
reason why they are evolutionarily
conserved because they consist of genes
that code for co-adapted proteins that
cannot just replace them with another
transcription factor of the same
another example is the hike highly
conserved gene regulatory Network and
underlying the development of insect
eyes it's also known to be extremely
conserved the contrast to the inductive
signals so so please character identity
networks are teens mostly transcription
factors and cofactors that are currently
necessary for the character identity and
they a transcription factor proteins
coded for by these genes cooperate in
regulating either each other as well as
the Tao the downstream target genes and
their auto-regulatory have a positive
feedback okay so so that's the basic
idea so how does this work out and help
us develop a research program to
understand the origin of novel things
noble identities if this is correct then
evolutionary novelty is a noble
character identity if we want to
understand the origin of a normal
character identity we have to understand
how the character the entity network for
the new body part originated with this
hypothesis which I say it's a hypothesis
we don't know whether it's true were
generalizable but at least with this
hypothesis we have something specific to
test experimentally right the best
example that I know of
that comes close to this notion is the
work by aunt artem cop from UC urban as
davis on the evolution of of a special
character on the male for arms they call
the sex combs that they use for
copulation it's a normal character
within a subgroup of Drosophila T's and
without me actually influencing what he
published in 2011 he actually also came
up with this model that the origin of of
the sex combs arises through the derived
feedback interaction between double sex
and sex comes reduced sex comes reduce
this necessary for transverse brittle
role that
and the interaction with double sexes
the one that then forms this
individualized bristle rows that are
known as as a sex comes in our own lab
I'm just very briefly say about how we
are going about using these ideas we are
looking into the evolution of a normal
cell type in particular there the citral
cells that are part of the uterine
endometrium that are necessary to deal
with the invasive pleasant ation kuru
king has shown that there are cells in
the meter of fibroblasts in there in
bhasu pills in the opossum but no deceit
well cells and we are trying to
understand how this is working our
current model is that the particular
regulatory gene fo'c'sle one was
probably recruited into the regulation
of the of these precursor cells and so
we are currently working both on the six
regulatory changes that lead to this
recruitment as well as we have already
published extensively on the evolution
of transcription factor cooperativity
between some of these genes and the
normal derived genes so just to tell you
that it's not just talk there's a real
work behind it as well okay okay now a
little detour into into a philosophy
what does this have to do with
metaphysics and in what way is taught
talking and thinking about homology has
to be limited linked to talking about
metaphysics even in the book have a
chapter in there that's called the long
shadow of metaphysics and research
programs and I fully expect to get a lot
of flack for that to have a metaphysics
chapter in a science book but the reason
is actually expressed here in this epic
reform Michel Kiesling who wrote it
should be clear by now that metaphysical
pre-conceptual profoundly influenced the
course of scientific investigation I
think that's even though we don't
reflect on metaphysical issues in our
daily research we make implicit
assumptions about
metaphysical concepts that sort of are
the background and also the limits for
what our research programs actually can
achieve and I think that and metaphysics
here I mean in particular the fact that
each science each module science has its
own ontology and our own ontology
meaning just a list of things that we
think is profound are real that is
necessary to talk about and the other
things are not you know not of our
concern the easiest for me is the
ontology of chemistry at least sort of
in a superficial way what you what what
we talked about in chemistry is atoms in
two parts neutrons protons electrons
molecules that are you know atoms stick
together
ions that you know atoms that lost again
some electrons and complexes that are
molecules that are hanging together by
weaker forces but essentially that's
what we are talking about right and
that's everything that's strictly
chemical of nature is in one way or the
other can be expressed in terms of atoms
molecules complexes air ions and so on
right now the same is true for
evolutionary biology the new synthesis
biology that has a very clear ontology
that things that we are willing to talk
about in the in that in the Indus
paradigm there are genes in particular
different alleles haplotypes of
genotypes phenotypes but only sort of as
a vehicle for other genes then we talk
about populations but mostly populations
in the sense of gene pools as
collections and frequencies of genes and
then species which are essentially
separate gene pools so that's roughly
what the population geneticist is
allowed to think about right in ten you
know design concepts that go with it or
linkage is equally at it if effects and
and and and and so on so the point that
I'm making is that there's a hole in
this list in this ontology and that is
the black box where the organism should
be right the individual the organism
that actually does biology right that
repartee sister does thing that eats and
death
and everything right mates and so but
that is not part of that ontology we
have no explicit way to talk about them
right to about the structure and their
importance at all they are sort of
somewhat intercept of fold it into the
notion of Fitness which is the only
phenotypic character that ik population
geneticist really cares about and that
is a reflection of a what has been
called the hardening of the new
synthesis I think it was Stephen Jay
Gould who came up with this term said
that you know that leads the notion of
evolution as just changes in gene
frequencies that's it right but if you
only think as evolution as changes of
gene frequencies very hard to introduce
any notions of phenotype complexity of
novelty of different forms of life you
know not even planes and animals exist
in this sort of reduced language right
so in talking about homology about
innovation you cannot do it within this
ontology so you have to find and find
out what kind of concepts or categories
we can use in order to to talk about now
one insidious consequence of this way of
thinking is that if natural selection is
the only causal factor that you are
accepting as an explanatory model then
any explanation has to remain within the
limits of a species right because
natural selection is only happening
through competition among members of the
same gene pool and you know that's
that's the end of it so a meaning that
you know when the population is is
splitting what's going on in this
population has nothing to do what's
going on in the other population so any
causal narrative has to remain within
the limits of a single species right on
the other hand any type concepts
homology concepts are always strands
Tran species trans-pacific comparisons
and that really leads to a problem is
this at all meaningful right and
thankfully two colleagues have expressed
is quite clearly Reef and Sherman took
the pains in 1993 to explain that any
talk about phylogenies and comparisons
of homology is nonsense because it would
mean that the ancestral species would
other mysteriously reach from the past
to clutch the throats of the descendants
meaning that any talk about things that
go beyond the limits of species would
imply that there's some kind of causal
connect connection that cannot exist
because causality ends at the boundaries
of species right so that shows how how
how difficult it is to overcome or to
extend our thinking if we stick to the
existing ontology of a particular
research program so they can ask about
alternative anthologies one is and say
that homology is an illusion we only a
residuum of similarity to the common
ancestry is not something that we need
to be concerned about right that's
certainly a possible position and you
know prominent biologist and
philosophers have have defended it but
there are some alternatives the other
alternative that we have in the
classical philosophical literature is to
read to talk about natural kinds and
essentialist natural kinds meaning that
thing is a particular kind of thing if
it has a particular essence like for
instance to be a carbon atom that you
have to have six protons that's the
essence right and so there has to have
some intrinsic property that makes it
what it is
right the argument however is that in
evolutionary biology in particular than
an argument by Michael ethylene and many
others is that in evolution there is no
such a unchangeable essence and
therefore they like to talk about
individuals there are things that have
no essence that have no intrinsic
necessary properties they have a
definite beginning and the
ancient there's a historical entity
stuff and they don't have instances
independent innocent but the only of
members like the members of the same
species are part of this process of the
continuation of this of the species
reproduction and so on while the carbon
you have different instances of carbon
atoms they don't need to be part of one
functional system to be still a carbon
atom right so those are the two
ontological categories that we have as a
at presence namely de essentialist
natural kinds or individuals now the
problem that I have with it as homology
the way I think about it fits neither of
those categories homologues I Grievous
whiskies lean have a definite historic
beginning as novelties and potentially
an antique entire article their lineage
has died out so the retrospective
behaved like an individual the form
lineages of descent so in that sense
there'll be like you can draw trees of
descent and modification of a particular
organ but they have some essential
properties namely they need to have a
mechanism that makes them different from
the rest of the body right the power
they need character identity network in
that respect they are not like
individuals like Kiessling has has
thought about it and they're often
conserved with respect to some
organizational features you know you
limbs and brains and things like that so
I think we need a new ontological
category which I could call homeostatic
individuals they have a beginning and a
potential end the for miniatures and
have historical continuity but it
requires specific mechanisms for the
individuation that respect they have
some things of like a nagging essence
but not an essential you know shape of
form or function and the individuating
mechanisms if my model is correct
actually a home will statically
maintained because of the necessity of
protein-protein interactions for their
transcription factors to do their work
right so they are homeostatic like
homeostatic property clusters of poit
they are still lineage historico
entities and and they have some things
that look like a little bit of an an
entity and I think I know used up my
time lot and I thank you for your
attendance and your attention thank you
very much great I'm gonna let you use
your or take your own questions but just
to help with the recording I'll ask that
when you ask a question you use this non
microphone or this microphone that's
only being recorded on the tape so
questions and I'll you can take them and
I'll hand out this mic
good turd so how will how do you see
identifying character identity networks
as kind of the way of identifying
evolutionary innovations in changing our
approach of thinking about evolutionary
innovation as from the empirical
perspective how will we how we actually
identify and individualize the sense of
hypothesis of evolutionary innovation
for every homology hypothesis that you
you know you're proposing a systematic
study you need to identify the character
identity network this it's also not the
case by describing species you have to
in every instance actually
experimentally show that they cannot
make babies we stay just in a neighbor
speech there are lots of indirect
criteria that you can use to make it
plausible that one species is distinct
from another one you know population
genetic Geographic and other evidence
and I think that the general you know
morphological criteria to identify
homologs is work actually pretty well I
think it only becomes necessary to refer
to a model or this model some other
model if you want to understand
mechanistically what happened when in
one descendant lineage something new
appears that doesn't seem to have a
course anything corresponding in a
sister lineage then you then think you
you have to do the heart we can actually
find try to find which part of the
developmental mechanisms are responsible
for character identity and which ones
are not incidental and then try to
understand how recruitment of genes or
who adaptation of transcription factor
genes leads to a new coherent character
identity network that then gives rise to
a new individual that has evolutionary
change of its own in evolutionary
history of its own different from the
rest of the body
thank you
John please yes so I was thinking about
the last thing he said and your sort of
new definition of the individuals is
homey static and I wondered if you had
applied that concept also to these ideas
of evolutionary transitions so we moved
from molecules to cells and cells to
multicellular and on up and if you would
apply this to any of those levels of
organization or really just individuals
as we think of as an organism no no it's
it's so that the idea is that at least
complex organisms consist of
individualized parts so an individual
individuality I mean any any parts that
is the offer of a multicellular most
multicellular organisms that acquired
developmental and genetic individuality
that makes them able to you know to
react to selective pressures differently
from the rest of the body right and they
have PI you know take on a specific
function and so on so individuality is
in this more general sense that starts
at at the cell level all the way up to
maybe even the sword so it's from a of a
colony right potentially I don't think
it's useful and actually necessary for
any subcellular thinks I mean at least
with molecular entities like genes and
so on because you know there's something
else going on there
tarek hoping and indels and and
recombination so on that I think it's
mechanistically a different a different
story then what's going on with with
phenotypic you know body body characters
Jack
like Gunter great so where does the gene
itself sit and this hierarchy where are
you on the side of should the homology
relation be that the gene or its
sequence or the I mean the sequence
determines determines the character
state or their allelic identity of a
gene right I mean it's it's technically
sometimes not not easy but in general a
gene is the corresponding DNA segment
that has been passed on from common
ancestors on and on right it of course
the sequence itself its function and
it's you know it's--it ain't it is
something that gets duplicated and only
in you know one copy transmitted to the
next to the next generation I mean there
are special cases like like the
ribosomal genes that have all this
homogenization where actually it's not
the individual gene that that's the
historical entity that changes over time
but it is the whole family of ribosomal
genes because they remain were the
homogenized each others did you remain
were similar to each other than any
instance in another species so that's
it's a little bit more complicated than
that but in when all this has to ask
what at what level is historical
continuity arising and what maintains it
I think in in the case of this ribosomal
genes it's different mechanisms gene
conversion and duplication and loss of
genes that homogenize them and make them
one unit of evolutionary change as
opposed to two other single genes you
know it's so I'm thinking that there is
no simple answer that that cuts in in
all directions but you always have to
ask
we're at what level of organization
historical continuity arises and what
causes it let's take this up to the
another level then to with about
cultures that reproduce themselves and
memes and here to my colleagues from the
humanities to answer that question I
mean that I shouldn't answer that but of
course as a Yale professor
I cannot restrain myself you know I mean
cultures are historical entity right
they exist because they are transmitted
at least elements of it transmitted from
generation to generation and you can
make an argument whether it's it holds
any water that it's not me to answer
that some elements of those of those
cultures have have individual continuity
right organization of the institutions
like we discussed last night you know
institutions have a life on their own
they are historical continuity they are
independent to some degree of the people
who represent the institution because
individuals come and go but they have a
rule system that makes sure that the
institution remains the same thing it
remains an University whether it remains
at church or remains a military
organization right but each of them have
have this property to whether any of
those ideas help us understand the
identity of those institutional
identities individuality I don't know
that that needs to be answered by people
who really understand the work
and so I'm interested in the in
character states and character networks
and if you take something as simple as a
virus are any changes in a virus ever
going to meet your definition for
novelty or are they all just going to be
changes in character states well I mean
if you have more if you duplicate a gene
and it differentiates right and creates
let's say a new coat protein that then
is inherited and you know each of these
two copies have you know taken in the
independent functions then you have a
novelty at that level I don't think any
of the ideas that I talked about about
networks and so on might be useful there
because I mostly what I thought about is
a consequence of the fact that these
structures are made up of multiple cells
whether there's something similar going
on at the gene regulatory level in
viruses I don't know this is something
you have to tell me at the next
committee meeting
only a quick comment in in in regard to
the the the gentleman who raised the
issue of culture I think that that's
that this is extraordinarily rich and
extraordinarily extraordinarily powerful
because I think that at another level up
in bio cultural coevolution there are in
fact moments at which at which there are
emergencies of complex networks of
systems that that did not exist before
that then come to be channeling
mechanisms whereby a reproduction of the
kind of the kind that you're calling
homologs
or will will in fact persist across
across cultural histories and not only
hominin cultural histories but cultural
histories and other species as well so I
think it's been fantastically
interesting work thank you that's all
please join me please join me for
reception and right directly downstairs
and let's thank winter again